hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
implications of rapid idh1 idh2
testing for liquid and solid tumors
presented by
sarah hurlihi precision and
computational diagnostics at the
hospital of the university of
pennsylvania
i am michelle ashton of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by abbott molecular for
more information on our sponsor
please visit www.abbott.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask the question box located on the far
left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
sarah hurlihi
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
sarah you may now begin your
presentation
thanks michelle hi all so first i want
to thank abbott molecular
and lab roots for inviting me to speak
today
i'm going to discuss with you about how
our laboratory has implemented rapid
molecular
idh1 and idh2 testing and the clinical
utility
of this test i hope that by the end of
today's presentation
you will be able to recognize the
clinical utility of having rapid
ivh1 and idh2 testing in both
hematological
and solid tumors as well as identify
laboratory workflow modifications that
allow for
efficient use of precious biopsy
specimen material
for disclosure support for this program
is provided by abbott and i am
presenting
at their request i'm going to begin
by discussing idh in the context of
hematological diseases with a focus on
acute myeloid leukemia
in which idh is commonly mutated i'll
present
the disease and the gene background in
the context of three case studies
these cases will highlight the
advantages of molecular testing
for idh at various stages of disease
progression
next i'll describe how our laboratory
was able to modify
our workflow to add idh testing without
requiring
additional specimen to be collected or
sent to the laboratory
finally i'll discuss the utility of idh
testing in solid
tumors and the study is completed to
achieve the same specimen use
efficiencies
i'll start with background on acute
myeloid leukemia or aml
which is a disease of the patapoetic
precursors in the
blood and bone marrow here clonal
transformation
in which a neoplastic transformed cell
population expands
may provide proliferative and survival
advantage and inhibit
normal hematopoietic differentiation
in the u.s there are approximately four
new cases per hundred thousand people
each year
aml is often described as an age-related
disease being
most common in older adults and much
rarer in those
under 45 years of age the median age of
onset is 68 years of age
from this data set of two years of cases
in the uk
highlights the age asparagus age
disparity
of disease onset as you can see that
there is a higher onset
with increasing age
besides an aging hematopoietic stem cell
population
previous exposures to high-dose
radiation
benzene and previous therapy exposures
are all risk factors for aml
in addition some lifestyle choices and
comorbidities such as chronic smoking
and obesity
can increase the risk of aml
the current world health organization
criteria for aml
is greater than or equal to 20 percent
blast in either the blood or the bone
marrow
and aml can then further be divided into
subgroups based on
ethiology pathology and genetic
alterations
these subgroups include aml with
recurrent
genetic abnormalities aml with
myogeoplastic related changes
therapy related neoplasm and aml
not otherwise specified ones that would
not fall into the previous three
categories
over 50 percent of aml patients have
some
cytogenetic abnormality and these are
translocations insertions or deletions
and inversions as you can see in the
graph to the right
they can also be a loss or gain of one
or more chromosomes
monozomes trisomies or polyploidies in
the graph
at the bottom of the slide
these cytogenetic changes allow for
stratification of aml patients into
favorable intermediate and poor risk
categories
the graph here shows the overall
survival
of patients in each of these risk
categories
and as you can see depending on which
category they fall into they have either
favorable
intermediate or a poor risk outcome
many genetic alterations can also
determine
patient stratification
this image depicts the molecular
landscape for aml at our institution
which correlates well with what is
presented in the literature
this represents about 800 specimens over
the course of five years
and while aml is heterogeneous there are
a handful of more
commonly observed mutations some of
these such as flit
which is the highest at our institution
and the ibh
1 and 2 mutations have targeted
therapies available that may be added to
treatment plans
once a variant has been identified today
we're going to focus on aml with the
genetic abnormalities specifically the
idh1 and idh2 variant
idh mutations are present in about 20
of aml's cases and again these are more
commonly seen in elderly adults
these mutations typically fall into an
intermediate risk category
and most of the people in these with
these mutations have a normal karyotype
they the idh one and two mutations can
frequently co-occur with mpm1
and srsf2 and less frequently with
split-3 mutations
idh which stands for isocitrate
dehydrogenase is a gene that codes for
an enzyme which catalyzes the reaction
of isocitrate
to alpha-ketoglutarate while idh1 and
idh2
have similar enzymatic functions idh1 is
localized
to the cytoplasm while idh2
is localized to the mitochondria a
mutated idh1
and idh2 create alpha-ketoglutarate
competitor
2-hydroxyglutarate this 2-hd
alters the cellular metabolism dna
methylation and differentiation
as well as competes for the normal
function of alpha-q glutarate
mutations typically occur in enzymatic
arginine residues of idh1 and idh2 genes
although rarer idh mutations have been
identified
these mutations occur at amino acid 132
of idh1
and residues 140 and 172 of idh2
mutations are not specifically changed
to
one amino acid for example an arginine
to a serine
but there are amino acids that are more
commonly substituted as
are depicted on the left a handful of
them for idh1
and a handful of them for idh2
this data from the same five years shows
the prevalence
of specific idh variants and aml from
our institution
the idh1 variants are found in about
six to ten percent of aml patients of
these variants
an arginine to either a cysteine or a
histidine are the most
common variants eight to 19 percent of
aml patients
will harbor an idh2 mutation
approximately 80
of these reside in the r140 residue
and an arginine to glutamine is the most
prevalent variant
an arginine to lysine that's position
172 is also common
especially in the elderly population
next i'm going to present three cases
which highlight the clinical utility
of rapid idh testing at various stages
of disease progression
and i will do this in the context of
clinical guidelines
our first case is a 76 year old woman
who presented with leukocytosis and
circulating blast
on her peripheral blood smear she showed
thrombocytopenia
and 66 glass with prominent nucleoli
these blasts were positive for mpo cd13
cd33 and cd 177 by flow cytometry
these findings were diagnostic of acute
myeloid leukemia
as shown in the molecular landscape
aml is a heterogeneous disease that can
often be described as unique
as each individual patient both the
karyotyping and molecular testing can
help define the disease and the
prognosis of these patients
and in some cases define
the therapy decisions an intensive
versus a low intensity therapy or
targeted therapy if a mutation is
present
recently a recent update to the mccn
guidelines for acute leukemia recommend
molecular
and cytogenetic analyses for actionable
mutations to be expedited to a maximum
of three to five days turnaround
time this list includes idh which we
will discuss momentarily
which has targeted therapies available
if we return to our first case our
molecular findings
a conventional chromosome analysis
showed a normal female karyotype
it was negative for fish studies for
deletions and rearrangements assessed
molecular testing on the peripheral
blood revealed no
rearrangement transcripts idh variants
or flit
itds an r140q
idh2 variant and a d835 to v
swit3 mutation were identified with
targeted molecular testing
these results were later confirmed with
a larger massively parallel sequencing
panel
which also identified mpm1 and srsf2
disease-associated variants
the integration of the clinical picture
molecular findings is critical
to clinical management of aml
highlighting the need for this rapid
testing
younger patients can often receive
intensive standard chemo induction
chemotherapy
but many other patients are unable to
tolerate such treatments and instead
receive a less intensive therapy
a less intensive therapy may also
include a targeted approach
to actionable mutation in addition to
treatment decisions molecular results
may also
aid in deciding when to go to transplant
if we return to this first case study
this patient who is over the age of 60
years old was not a good candidate for
intensive therapy due to her poor
performance status
the mccn guidelines differentiate
treatment
induction strategies for those who are
not intensive therapy candidates
into groups with actionable mutations
and those with us
without an actionable mutation
per the mccn guidelines patients with a
de novo aml
and an idh 1 or 2 mutation may benefit
from venetoclax
with a hyper-methylating agent-based
therapy
given her idh2 mutation this patient was
considered an excellent candidate for
vidasa venetoclax upfront treatment
molecular idh results of this case were
returned within 48 hours
and this allowed the ability to rapidly
decide on therapy incorporating the
clinical considerations and
mutational status
due to the rapidity of testing both of
these findings integrated
highlight the utility of rapid idh
testing and induction chemotherapy
decisions
following a successful induction these
targeted therapies may also be added to
post-induction treatment plans if not
utilized up front
while testing a diagnosis is clearly
advantageous
what about testing for residual disease
or relapse
a clear picture of residual disease
testing for idh
is still being debated many idh variants
are persistent
even following therapy but recent
literature suggests that idh detection
may be an early sign of relapse
in the context of relapse recurrence and
also emergence of
de novo idh variants may be observed
nccn guidelines recommend testing for
actionable
genes including ivh1 and two idh
mutational status may
additionally aid in second line therapy
decision
this second case is a 68 year old woman
with a history of cmml
she had previously received six cycles
of videzo without a response
upon review at our institution she
presented with dysplasia of the
granulocytes and monocytes
her bone marrow biopsy was consistent
with refractory cml with increased blast
while this case is not aml it is
considered a high risk
myelocorporative neoplasm
her karyotype was normal with molecular
findings of an idh2
r172k variant no idh1 variants were
detected
this molecular finding was confirmed
later on the mps panel
that also identified an asxl1 dnmt2
and k-rest variant
as with diagnosis actionable mutations
should be determined at the time of
relapse
relapse here and the guidelines for nccn
showing that split 3 idh1 and idh2
should be
monitored therapy for relapse disease
includes clinical trials and targeted
therapy including those for idh1 and
idh2
due to the high risk disease and the
presence of idh2 variant this patient
met criteria for a clinical
trial with endocytome although
this is not aml the second case
highlights the utility of rapid testing
and relapsing disease
identifying therapeutic options
including clinical trials and targeted
therapy to determine changes
in molecular based prognosis and risk
stratification
targeted therapies against idh1 and idh2
selectively bind and impair enzymatic
activity
these decrease two hd productions and
allow more normal function of alpha-q
glutarate function
these actions also allow normal cell
metabolism
and differentiation
the idh1 inhibitor ivocytonib was
approved for use in revlaps and
refractory aml
in july of 2018 and for frontline aml
in may of 2019 the idh2 inhibitor is
currently only approved for
relapse and refractory use in aml
in a phase 1 2 study for the idh2
inhibitor
in mutated aml 19 19
of patients achieved a complete
remission with an overall survival of
19.7 months those with partial
remission had an overall survival of
14.4 a month
as shown here the median survival is 9.3
months
a phase 1 study in idh1 mutated relapse
and refractory aml
also showed promising results with
greater than 21
of patients achieving complete remission
and an overall median survival of
8.8 months this is markedly better than
those with
no response or those with other than a
complete remission
the third case is a 75 year old woman
presenting with neutropenia and
circulating blasts
her presentation and molecular studies
were performed at an outside hospital
and via sendout testing upon internal
review of the aspirate 44
blacks were observed and she was
diagnosed with aml
not otherwise specified
per the outside hospital report she had
a normal karyotype and normal fish
results
in-house molecular testing identified no
flip 3 variants
the sample for sequencing was deemed
quality not sufficient
this case presented just prior to our go
live of rapid idh testing so none was
performed
at the time of diagnosis
she underwent induction chemotherapy
followed by vidasa venetoclax
and unfortunately did not achieve
remission follow-up molecular testing at
this time
revealed again no foot 3 variant but
detected an idh1 variant
the idh1 result was confirmed by
sequencing
this case highlights the advantage of
rapid idh testing
frontline targeted idh therapy combined
with standard
induction is well tolerated in trials
the beat aml trial subsidy with idh2
inhibitors
used continuous 28 day cycles in newly
diagnosed patients
who were younger than 60 years and
achieved a complete remission of 43
the extension of the idh1 trial that led
to frontline use approval
boasted an overall response rate of near
59 percent
while we don't know for sure if the
variant was present at the disease onset
for this patient
the implementation of rapid idh testing
and an idh1 inhibitor
approved for frontline use may have been
added to therapy
had the idh variant been detected at
diagnosis
this case highlights
the ability for rapid testing to allow
frontline targeted therapy decisions
in this next part i'll discuss how we
were able to adjust
our laboratory workflows and accommodate
an additional leukemia test without
requiring
additional material
new leukemia testing from blood and bone
marrow requires sample to be processed
for many analyses including
hematopathology first my slide and smear
review
flow cytometry karyotyping fish
and molecular studies
with limited sample volumes and an
increasing number of required molecular
tests
it can be challenging to implement these
new tests especially those that require
different extraction methods
the feasibility of stretching the sample
across all of these tests
led us to evaluate pairing our own
extraction with an fda
approved idh1 idh2 test
the abbott real-time idh1 and idh2
assays use homogeneous real-time
fluorescent technology to identify
single nucleotide variants in idh1 or
idh2
this chart at the bottom of the slide
lists the variants that are detectable
by the assays
while this list is not all inclusive
inclusive it covers the
most common variant the variant calling
is performed on the abbott m2000rt
software in a proprietary algorithm that
reports a qualitative
positive or not detected result
in order to implement this testing our
workflow would have been as follows
from the blood which we'll follow here
we would need 200 microliters of blood
to extract for idh testing
200 microliters to extract for dna for
other
aml targets and one to four mils for rna
extraction for other aml targets
while this workflow is not impossible it
leaves no room for re-extraction when
samples are not ideal which is not
uncommon in this patient population
it also creates a complex workflow
requiring three independent extractions
not including the extraction required
for sequencing
for one sample of molecular testing
additionally the idh1 assay has
an additional dilution step compared to
the idh2
making downstream preparation more time
consuming and challenging
our goals were to evaluate a streamlined
workflow by standardizing
dna extraction and sample processing
between the two
assays with the hope of reducing the
sample amount and time required
the following was our proposed workflow
to standardize the protocols and dna
extraction
in this workflow from the blood we take
200 microliters
of blood for dna extraction and one to
four
mils of blood for rna extraction
these specimens in our study design were
extracted in parallel
on both methods dna was then analyzed
on the idh1 and idh2 assays
with the addition of the dilution step
to the idh2
protocol
all reactions for both idh1 and idh2
were concordant the asterisk
here represents one sample that was
analyzed at an outside laboratory
that was using the abbott idh assays
the kaya amp extraction and standardized
idh1 and idh2 protocols were then
utilized for the remainder of our
studies
archived dna with known idh status was
used to assess the agreement
of the idh1 and idh2 assays we tested
all variants that were available as
shown in the table at the bottom
and all of our specimens were concordant
between sequencing and the idh1
and sequencing and the idh2 assays
we then assessed any changes in the
limit of detection with workflow
modifications
in samples with enough material variant
allele frequencies
dilutions were made and run in
triplicate dilutions
above at and below the manufacturer lod
were evaluated
the lod was determined to be equivalent
to the manufacturer's stated lod
of at least two percent vaf
in lieu of time today other performance
characteristics are not shown
but we also evaluated precision
specificity and dna
input as part of these studies
molecular testing is essential for both
risk ratification and therapeutic
decisions and aml
diagnosis and relapse in order to
facilitate this rapid testing
we assessed workflow modifications in
idh1 and idh2 testing
we found that these modifications were
able to streamline the dna
extraction and normalize the assays
and gave concordant results with our
sequencing
it also had a comparable lod to the
original assay
these changes allow us a more cohesive
aml workflow
without requiring additional starting
samples
in this final part i want to discuss the
role of idh testing in solid tumors
and our studies to validate these
specimens
our final case is a 27 year old male who
presented with headaches
auditory hallucinations and seizures a
head ct and mri
showed a right temporal lobe mass that
was suggestive of an idh mutant glioma
in cns tumors idh variants are seen in
about
80 to 90 percent of astrocytomas and
oleodendrogliomas
and approximately 10 of glioblastomas
the most prevalent
variant in idh1 is r132h
in 2016 the world health organization
updated their guidelines for cns tumor
following histology idh mutations are
the next determining factor
in diagnostic flow charts since
immunohistochemistry typically detects
only a singular idh1 variant negative
ihc results will still need their idh
status verified
to move to diagnosis
in cns tumors idh mutated patients have
an
improved probability of survival over
those who are idh wild
type as seen in these charts
is clear that an idh mutation can then
serve in both
a diagnostic and prognostic
role in cns tumors
the molecular testing we expected from
our neuropathology colleagues were those
with very limited
materials that could not be run on
sequencing those with challenging
ihc studies and those that are truly
stat in nature
in this case of the 27 year old male ihc
was negative
for the idh1 variant r132h
the ifc also showed a positive tp53
staining and loss of atrx expression
however since this case was suggestive
of an idh
mutant astrocytoma the sample was sent
for idh12
rtpcr
since the abbott real-time idh1 and idh2
assays are only approved for blood and
bone marrow we needed to validate the
use of paraffin-embedded tissue as a
specimen type
we first evaluated the required dna
input
here a range of dna inputs were assessed
some which fell outside of the suggested
inputs for the blood and bone marrow by
manufacturer
and these graphs just show the range of
dna inputs that we used
a total of 196 idh1 reactions and 106
idh2 reactions were assessed low levels
of dna input resulted in low-level
amplification
of the internal control dna input above
5 nanograms was concordant we
determined that consistent with the
requirements for blood and bone
marrow 10 nanograms of dna input
was required for paraffin-embedded
tissue
similar to our blood and bone marrow
evaluation samples with known idh
results by sequencing were assessed
these were paraffin-embedded tissue from
brain resections
a single sample was detected on
sequencing that was not detected by pcr
noted by an asterisk here and this
variant was not one that was expected
to be detected by the pcr having an
e226k
variant this sample was excluded from
concordance calculations
which were 100 between sequencing
and the idh1 and idh2 assays
additionally comparison of
immunohistochemistry to the idh1
assay was completed since the ihc only
detects
r132h variant there were four specimens
with additional variants detected by pcr
these are represented by the four in
parentheses in the graph
and our variance r132c g
and l a single specimen with r132h
positivity by pcr was not detected on
the ihc
this specimen was reclassified as a true
false negative by ihc
and may represent a higher sensitivity
of the pcr
assay over ihd detection
similar to our previous studies vaf
solutions of paraffin-embedded tissue
specimens were run in triplicate
all of these replicas were concordant
consistent with the lod
in blood and bone marrow detection of
ivh1 variant
was 100 accurate down to at least two
percent
vas it is likely that these variants are
accurate below this level
based on these studies
returning to our case study the pcr
results were positive for an idh1
variant
of r132l which is expected to be missed
by
ihc the final integrated diagnosis was
diffuse
astrocytoma with idh mutant
this case illustrates that rtbcr can be
an aid in diagnosis in solid tumor cases
especially where ihc and pathology are
conflicting
in this last part i hope i've been able
to show you the idh testing in glioma is
beneficial for both diagnosis
and prognosis we've been able to bring
on idh1 and 2 testing for pep specimens
again without additional sample
requirements
this method can serve as improved
detection
compared to ihc where sample quality may
not be sufficient for sequencing
evaluation in solid tumors is not
necessarily limited to gliomas
emerging literature and clinical trials
consider the utility
of the idh inhibitors and other solid
tumors with idh mutation
in the future the need for this idh
testing may be greatly expanded
in conclusion idh testing is beneficial
in both liquid and solid tumors
at many stages from diagnosis to
prognostic determination
to relapse modified workflows allow a
streamlined
testing on both liquid and tissue
specimens
with minimal specimen requirements
with that i'd like to thank many members
of the molecular pathology lab
especially alicia who performed
a number of the validation experiments
i'm sophia who helped me
pull the relevant information from the
aml cases
thank you and with that i will take any
questions
thank you sarah for your informative
presentation we'll now start the q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for all right let's go ahead
and get started
okay sarah your first question is when
performing the various
analysis for aml patients what is the
timing on the various molecular results
and are you able to present the
karyotype
fish and molecular results at the same
time
that's a great question thanks for that
unfortunately
there isn't a straightforward answer the
timing of testing depends
highly on the draw and when the specimen
is received into the laboratory
typically fish flit and idh results are
rapid enough to be able to be
incorporated
into our surgical pathology reports we
aim to have
the actionable mutations reported within
three days so that the physicians can
utilize these results for clinical
management decisions
but due to the nature of testing the
karyotyping
and the sequencing results are often
reported later
after treatments may have started
great thank you okay your next question
for glioblastoma cases do you wait for
ihc results to come back
prior to performing the rtidh testing
we do wait for the ihc results for
gliomas we've really tried to refine the
use case
and ihc is the most rapid and cheapest
methodology so we typically perform that
first and then in cases that have
conflicting ihc and pathology we would
reflex those to pcr
and other cases where we might be
utilizing the rtpcr
assay would be those where there's not a
quality
efficient material for sequencing those
that might be truly statin nature
it can also be age dependent some cases
in
patients younger than 55 years old need
to have the idh mutation ruled out
and so we would perform rtbcr in some of
those cases as well
great thanks sarah okay we've got time
for one more question let's go ahead
and go with this one it says what is the
difference between the amount of tissue
needed for rt and mps testing
in pet samples
yeah so this is a multifaceted
answer um if we directly compare the
input amounts
the rt requires a minimum of 10
nanograms
while sequencing panels will typically
work
10 to 30 fold more material depending on
the level of degradation of the
paraffin embedded tissue specimen we do
have a hot
hot spot sequencing panel with optimized
lower inputs which helps to kind of
reduce the number of samples
deemed as quality not sufficient i think
in general the pcr assays are a little
bit more forgiving in terms of the
sample degradation
and tumor percentage required compared
to the sequencing assays
thank you again sarah do you have any
final comments for our audience before
we go today
uh i just want to thank everyone for
listening and for
your interesting questions and thank lab
roots and
abbott molecular for inviting me to
speak thank you
great thank you and before we go i'd
also like to thank the audience for
joining us today
any questions we did not have time for
today will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration we would
like to thank you sarah for your time
today in your important research
we would also like to thank labyrinth
and our sponsor abbott molecular for
underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand
and labyrinths will alert you when it's
available for replay
until next time goodbye